[Music]
hello everyone happy Monday how's it
going hope you guys are doing long had a
great weekend and we are back at its
Morgan's all the action our chastity is
here and you guys already know if I had
something Pokemon going on I had to get
chastity on here it's either chastity or
Kali I remember key today in the chair
right now thank you guys for joining us
today we are playing pokemon mystery
dungeon rescue team DX that is a mouse
but it is a remake you guys might
remember the originals way back in the
day 2005 yes red and blue but now
they've been combined for this remake
and it is remake it's got a new art
style compared to the 8-bit you guys
have seen before and then of the
classics you know so yeah it's new it
came out Friday yeah the six so it's
only been out since the sixth and yeah
I'm pretty excited to see this new art
style I actually personally haven't
played the game I was a little too old
for at the time but now I'm just like
that was a really dumb way of thinking
cuz I now I never feel too old for
Pokemon but at the time I thought so I
was like I'm in you know yeah but I'm
really excited to jump into this because
I've heard good things and I heard that
this is a really good version of it and
that the art is adorable and the muse
it's really cute right now just arriving
out to this mini music here yeah I'm
excited to check it out too because I
didn't catch the originals by 2005 I was
all in on like Halo so all of my like
other games they just collected dust and
I'm like I can't even remember what I
was doing in 2000 I think I was working
at bands
I was playing something I was placed up
on a Playstation but it wasn't playing
this game but I'm excited to see what
this is good thing about remakes now is
like I'm getting a new chance yes I got
a lot of games yeah so this is on the
switch this just came out on Friday and
you're gonna turn into a Pokemon I think
that's super exciting
it's excited it's based on a personality
quiz and so there are several Pokemon
that you could turn into I'm really just
crossing my fingers if any of you know
me at all I'm crossing my fingers for
side up or to partner with side off
because I love science so much number
one sign a fan but yeah there are a
number that you can become Bulbasaur
squirtle Charmander cyndaquil Totodile
she can read a Treecko Torchic Mudkip
Pikachu eating my shop cubone side up
Meowth and skiddy so let's see if you
are let's just hope for the best
yeah they want me to answer them
sincerely I will I was
only try my best I'm ready okay let the
interview begin here we go a lot of
pressure yeah it's like this is going
deep yeah what's your inner Pokemon
first I'm curious about these questions
is it a pleasant day at the beach oh it
is a pleasant day at the beach how do
you feel this feels great I think you
would be into the sunshine yes on
vacation outings you want to go with
them
do you like groan inducing puns I do I
do about where you stand on fines
definitely I'm always the one who groans
but lucky I enjoy it a hundred percent
I'm I'm out whenever like summer
co-workers Tweetup funds or whatever and
I just I just like I'm like I'm not
gonna like this but I laughs I just want
you to know that I left but I'm not
gonna like this cuz I don't want to hear
I'm gonna go with okay I really do love
them in your heart of her exactly we
love puns so we're looking for a cheesy
Pokemon yeah a foreign person has
started up a conversation with you all
right
to be honest you don't have a clue what
this fellow is saying how do you reply
haha yes very funny could you could you
say that again right well I gotta go I
kind of feel like I would never be any
of yours no you're like somewhere
between the first two yeah exactly
but you're not like exactly number one
exactly number two but I'm also it's
hard to interpret tone on this because
we're reading it via text I think you're
on top yeah I do the number one I think
so too very funny okay cool I would at
least laugh if they laughed I think I
would naturally just laugh too if I
didn't know what their done what do you
do with your room's light when you go
into bed at night I turn it off yeah I
believe complete darkness as well I'm on
the same page as you right now your
friend fails to show up for a meeting at
the promised time what do you do
wait patiently get angry and bail I'll
definitely wait till they get there for
sure thank you cuz I'm the friend that
you're waiting I'm always lookin very
sorry
things happened yes okay oh boy all
right you sometimes run out of things to
do all of a sudden oh really
there's always something there's always
there's people there always games to
play in this world you never run out of
games you're suddenly locked inside a
pitch-black room this is terrifying what
do you do cry or clean it come on
no we're not cleaning this room it's
pitch black its pitch black how do you
know where the door is she's gonna be
kicking walls yeah all right I think I'm
gonna go with this completely fair
you once you play as a boy or a girl you
I change it up I know game the game my
changes oh yeah today no girl power
all right into it DCC say go team
Psyduck hell yeah and then gemma also
said side doc I am all right
good jolly tape yes always laughing and
smiling you I think they were too
positive to be side up based on the
answers that we gave I think from the
answers that we gave a very Pikachu like
we're very squirtle like have lots of
friends well we also said we like state
we also something like puns so we might
be now I don't know we're definitely a
starter Pokemon I think and probably not
me I suppose you get carried away you
should learn to sing hey Tony girls
really cute these cute I'm not mad it
looks like he tries to be like you know
intimidating and doesn't work and I feel
like that's me know what this is a good
match there's good match Totodile is
really key you think it again if you
guys don't like yeah we're going on
you know this is meant to be I am sure
it don't question the system I get to
choose your friend
okay well I'm issues scientist side
that's not here anymore
Saito's doesn't get to be a partner this
is very upsetting so you can't be the
same type as you so don't go with them
yeah so there's no water types that's
why I show because we can't up to water
types in the same team especially at the
beginning well I'll let you pick so
since we've got a water you want
something else you want a go grass or
fire do you like
Charmander I want one of the originals
you watch try mine or do you want
Bulbasaur lets you check all right let's
do it
fire and water yes
we will gonna homie in there right keeps
you do you guys remember that episode of
the anime of Pokemon where Charmander
was waiting on that rock
for his master and I just cried I was
very upset it was a sad time
oh there Charmander I'm gonna change it
to Charlie Charlie the Charles s magic
Charlie I'm okay with children that's
fine but I wish I got a psychic but the
way we answered I am I that makes total
sense
alright Charlie the Charmander is our
partner yes yes but he looks like it's
Charlie oh look at these friends two
best bud yeah fire and water here we go
lizard teams at arrow yep team lizard
what up a posh is that I saw a Pikachu
and I had to come over yeah it's a
really cute thumbnail Thank You Steven
for making that thumbnail for us where
am I am I dreaming this so this is your
gonna notice if you guys haven't played
the original
or played this version yet it's
different from the other Pokemon games
this is more of a dungeon crawler and
you're going around as teams sometimes
you're helping out Pokemon that need
help sometimes you're just trying to
make some money we'll see what happens
please wake me up in my heart I'm
psychic but this isn't yeah a cache
sampson said Charlie and Toto toto and
Charlie I love it
that's totally their names he were
passed out here buddy Mike yeah it was
rough night and you are
I've never seen you around before let's
be best friends
I don't believe you you look like a
lizard so we're a human inside a
totodile body oh I love the sad fate fun
Charlie's just it's stupid yeah your
name okay here's where I can officially
become Toto toto
[Music]
boom
Toto and Charlie it's the adventures of
Toto and Charlie watch that meets I love
the arts and for this good someone needs
something
Butterfree what's the problem Oh
gotta save a baby oh my go get we got to
help this baby no no no let's do it
together what will become of my baby
[Music]
Oh beer will Butterfree help these
already stressed out enough we got this
like I said make sure Toto sings Africa
yes what is your favorite Pokemon
aspirin and mine is Psyduck even though
I'm wearing a Gurkha hat mine is so
beyond choice
it's a mystery dungeon a truly
mysterious place Malaya and the items
change every time you enter I had to
know to find the stairs first yes there
is a Fisher
mmm-hmm oh no sorry we have to fight
let's do our best Soto I played a lot of
DFO like dungeon fighter online so
that's like the gist of my dungeon you
see with a owning it just automatically
picks the best one for you just use at
the click a nice burst oh that was
Charlie
Charlie's feeling feisty today alright
so far it's pretty easy but I mean it's
just starting out there's gonna be a
strategy later on yeah also I feel bad
they were like just sleeping
[Music]
you yellow teammates green items blue
enemy is red stairs white got it
[Music]
they're also talking trash now as a
string shot was gonna do anything
the Totodile Oran berry to restore some
HP to eat more on press effects you're
good this is probably easier using the
d-pad instead of the left stick press L
oh now we're zooming wait there's stuff
I wanted to see oh yeah Carly spin
Rebecca said my favorite Pokemon his
Blaziken
he's also victorious go on I don't think
so in front of me it's just vinegar rub
hurry I'll check out what's over here
before we go down yes Aaron is kidding
oh it's just my money gotta get that
money
interesting so auto-mode took us to the
money first when we're in took us for
the stairs I assume as it would it be
the other way around anything takes you
directly to the next place to go to
yes we would like to go tiny woods
don't attack sleeping Pokemon but if you
have to yo thanks charlie picking that
up so much money
[Music]
nice one hit nothing good job charlie
easy alright he woke him up oh no
Charlie broke the rule it wasn't me
Charlie is just he's a firecracker in
movies he's just ready to fight this is
what they're actually saying whenever we
hear them just know let's go he's gonna
be in our group now oh I thought we had
to like make our way back home with him
[Music]
yes The Adventures of Toto and Charlie I
love it we have more inside a club in
the chat sorry doc so great oh I love
the pictures of them in the bottom right
so now the baby we just saved I guess
has a crush on toto Sierra
I'm gonna idolize you guys shoot what do
we get
thank you a seed who in the berry and
500 days
all right I need to go save babies now
because they're making all the money
[Laughter]
good job charlie do you want to hang out
do you wanna be friends
Wow Charlie is so generous oh you wanna
come on adventure of course we do it is
amazing
can you play this game as two players no
it's one player it yeah yeah I think so
I didn't see any options for a co-op
although this would be awesome that
would be again I can't explain but I'm
happy
[Music]
for this we all need to be pokey
[Music]
it doesn't matter yes
oh it's very nice of you oh the little
friends I love it's a male let's go save
them all we have to help all the pokemon
Charlie's a good pokémon all right well
I like how you handle yourself
now we're another interviewer yes I
would like to join your team the world's
best rescue team
why would someone else know we're doing
it can't play the game what's the game
isn't exactly game over you didn't join
the rest
yeah jee-m'nee
what do you like would be the name man
lizard lizard
wait is that something oh man this is
always the hardest part
[Music]
what what lizard bros usually it's a
chat if you guys don't pick it close
your browser
the lizard bros
[Music]
well it fit hope I can get by don't put
a space those are gross there we go team
up yes is lubbers okay yes I like it
it's a good name one more thing that's
adorable
don't you feel thank ya they're so cute
yeah they were selling plush dolls of
these yeah with the lay carps around
their neck it's so cute anyway we're
team lizard bros this is Charlie Oh toto
Charlie in total forever oooh team
Charlie doe to read oh thanks for the
names name suggestions we're going with
lizard bros though oh my goodness look
how I love it so much I can't handle it
that is how and that is how toto and
Charlie became best friends as a rescue
team alright top to your intro right
here so that's just a basically a giant
prologue that you playing through so I'm
cool with us being toto and Charlie
they've warmed my heart I'm sad that I'm
not side up that's okay that's fine I
just want to meet a psychic can we help
save a side up ooh
by the time the stream is over you take
a nice nap
awesome his bow looks like a leaf I'm
still the thing what is that supposed to
mean
oh yeah human yeah I think he's talking
about how he felt I would be transformed
into a Pokemon I think I'd be pretty
pleased I mean I'd be sad about like
whether and I was gonna change back but
I do I could just go about my day as a
pokemon I'd be the worst thing in the
world
um actually Brandon we will be streaming
some morazán tomorrow so make sure you
do you check that out tomorrow how you
forget your best friend's Haley gave you
this place to live how are you this
forgetful you only learned one name
yesterday like me that sounds really
honest
I'm also bad but only usually if I'm
meeting more than one person at once I'm
right that I can remember at least one
like the only phrase and we've and they
gave me a place to live yeah I got to
walk around me just take a little bath
first no baths we gotta find Charlie
oh that woods gonna set on fire huh you
should have slept in our house
Charlie Charlie where you outside
Oh Oh he was the second there I need a
best friend I'm gonna walk out my front
door I'm Charlie losing my best friend
our mailbox though we love it yeah
everyone needs help we need to find this
out
[Music]
oh yeah maybe there's something in the
mailbox there's a lot in the mailbox
Charlie who do we help first how do I
decide who's out here at dawn and it
took him till no one checked I knew it'd
be here rescue team starter set it was
give you one if you start a rescue team
who is they what's in it
there was a badge
nice there was a toolbox good there was
Pokemon news what's the news carry items
got it uh-huh so you've got that seed
from Butterfree and the berry can we
read the news
all right maybe we believe he's so sad
yeah everything yes
it's true we got to advertise maybe
Butterfree can tell their friends Oh got
lots of mail so cute the word of mouth
from Butterfree maybe right we saved her
baby I heard about you from Caterpie we
need your help Magnemite is in trouble
a strange electromagnetic wave flowed
through a dungeon and it's stuck
Magnemite and Magneton
[Music]
to form a Magneton it's not complete
please we need help already signed
magnets friends so this seems to be
pretty true to the original I think if I
saw the beginning of the original ones
and it sounds similar in the first
mission you guys can correct me on that
yeah it's just got a new art style so
cute the cool thing about this one is
the originals were separated from red
and blue but this one has all the
pokemons from both in one game nice
you're here oh you're here
[Music]
the food remember that is 36
they were so serious Tony can t remember
Charlie's name worried hope be and press
l to death move over to - yep cool got
some berries got an apple got a seed
he's sleeping thanks thanks sure had my
back we tried to be pacifists stupid
buddies just tried to bite us walk too
close
oh yeah he's like right there yo Charlie
yeah Charlie was a good partner I think
we made a good choice
I know it this music laughing right now
oh yes the music is coming from the game
Sam
[Music]
where your opponent's take your time and
choose actions wisely okay okay so just
let Charlie handle it we'll just walk
around let us lead the way that's an
important job I mean have you seen him
when he's leading look at that look at
that making him dance to walk the egg
all sorts of items
hazing like oh yeah to choose which
movie one
okay what would you like to do Oh oh he
was kinky yeah - hurts
[Music]
keep that in mind so if we fail we lose
all the items that we collected pretty
typical but we start the dungeon over
and collect more wonder wonder to lower
sets we return to normal so it's like
heels
those circuits it's money
[Music]
Charmander is actually the best partner
right now try miners just really don't
even let give me time to look at him
uses like a big fan okay
saw the little move on yeah if
traffickers lose a fight or the Pokemon
can be like charlie bit my goodness that
video it's great teams
[Music]
get out of here yeah the wombo combo
right there
yeah super you
[Music]
if we're going the right way we're
figuring it out okay get that money
charlie oh oh I can't charlie love about
you nice let's go even though he's been
doing all the work I see some stairs up
there but curiosity just gotta check
everything and I want to go around these
I like want to know where everything
that's involved yeah before I move on
ouchy
[Music]
sometimes power up as you use them on
those gauge changes and when it's full
the move will power up increasing power
accuracy you might be okay
balloon when tre well since he hit me on
this real quick
what is this gauge on the top ray it's
like going down slowly that's a good
question I'm scared
oh we find that for clothes really knows
what he's doing at least you have to
decide for him it kind of does its own
thing yeah oh I'm getting home thank you
your known contest that's your final
meter when I guess the zero your health
goes down that yes
oh they're both sleeping and Hispanics
you guys sneak right by him to sneak
right back they look adorable you're
fine
let him rest there's stuck together
let's get them out safely
this is very wholesome it is I love that
art rejoice tell your friends exactly
where to mouth we accept tips
yay they got him and a Mooney nice
[Music]
Oh get some rest
don't sleep outside I know right or
maybe we should wake up early oh it's
nighttime okay I thought we're gonna
wake up in the middle of the night are
you dreaming my pokey thoughts well
we're still a human inside a totodile
body interesting
[Music]
how do the Magnum IDE array get crushed
good question
check the mail there's the mail it never
fails
makes me wanna wag my tail what do we
got
Oh No thank you letters it's without me
do we got any missions
oh don't be discouraged surely I know
he's so like logical nothing we just
started Pokemon Square thank you there
we go
going on an adventure the little hop
just gives me anything so cute oh nice
alright it's officially guys we need a
pokemon theme park world please yes I
would love that
[Music]
the big thing
we have money to save
[Music]
link moves for you nice
what's linking if you like moves you can
use them together at the same time
sounds a good idea
[Music]
hmm I get it
everywhere friendly well consoles was
the game on this is on the switch
Nintendo solutions just came out on
Friday this is pokemon mystery dungeon
rescue team D X nice we have a dojo some
training
[Music]
yes Ben that is your boy Totodile what's
up then if you missed it earlier Persia
took the personality quiz and it decided
that she was each other though hey this
is some pretty good life advice yeah
your partner will sell you all kinds of
things when you're not sure where to go
just ask your partner
that's good life advice let's go to the
post office get some more jobs gal oh
the waddles
raxil says be honest what do you think
of the game so far I think it's adorable
I like the art and I think it's you know
that we're so early in its in its not
kind of fair to make an assessment at
this point like we've basically only
done one mission after a prologue but I
mean you know it's it's accessible is
what I would say I would say I love the
artwork and the music it's all super
cute
it's very wholesome yeah I really really
love this like aesthetic and then I
would say gameplay wise we've only done
like two dungeons so it hasn't like been
difficult but I think it's worth keeping
in mind that I do think this is more
tailored towards kids yeah though it's
not I don't expect it to get much more
difficult right this definitely feels
like a kids game but yet it's extremely
accessible but if you like pokemons you
don't have to be a play this we took all
the junk yes no jobs for anyone else we
got to get our wait I'm sad and lonely
can we help that how do we help them I
think lion does Voltorb go to Tania
woods okay how do they get their
listings onto the bulletin board if
they're okay
AEE yes Ben he does look like he's
wearing a bow tie but I think it's also
some kind of bandana it's like you can't
really see yeah I think if it's a girl
Pokemon it's a little bow if it's a boy
it's like tie to got it it's cute
I'm only seeing that because we pick
like boy and girl so mm-hmm
I don't know I get I'm assuming that's
why it's like all right attached to the
artist great hand-drawn backgrounds of
3d characters for us yes I agree it's
gorgeous
I really like parently the story gets
surprisingly dark did we accept the jobs
okay yeah maybe it's I looked in my
accepting jobs in inset as in their pit
bull and had all four of them and let's
go to the dungeon
the waddles
Sparkle around me and that's fine but
you'll get a lot of stuff Coons and get
almost twice the normal amount of money
and a lot of trappers we move right well
we gotta go see I want to go to tell my
boyfriend yes can't be greedy we're just
a humble recipe this should be a quick
one it was I think it's one of the first
ones in the original game only takes a
couple minutes oh I see I see that the
little dots are moving as we move and
they have the different colors yeah oh
man Charlie they're getting stronger
well I said what is this exactly this is
pokemon mystery dungeon rescue team DX
it's a remake of a 2005 game there were
two versions red and blue but yeah this
is a remake and with new arts and it's a
dungeon crawler with Pokemon but the
premise is that you're a human and you
wake up and you are suddenly a Pokemon
and then you make friends with a Pokemon
partner and you guys form a team and
then you help save other Pokemon and
make some money
[Music]
Hey
someone left no that was fast
don't worry be our friends all right you
got it
thank you the drama's for fixing Mike
number two huh pretty sad you guys sound
great thank you yes yeah well that was a
quick one I just wanted to help that
poor lonely boy yay on to the next yeah
Richie I do
she her volume was up but I decided says
like you're more louder than projected
projected I still have mine a little
lower out of habit from the other one oh
[Music]
thanks buddy sent it to storage
can we only do two great herding one per
day I mean it takes it out of them
they're so tired but that was a really
quick one I feel like they could have
done too I could have done two more one
day I love them just straight up like
face really deeper are you back sleeper
exactly like totally touched down in the
pillow they really nailed it with this
personality that's not another level
yeah he's here this time
oh no oh another Fisher oh hey
tunnels everywhere here's where we can
now see that it is a nose and not a
mouth because I always thought it was a
nose
[Music]
oh snap sass travel thanks Diglett no
Sam we're saving other book when I think
we're the only transformed human that we
know of at the moment but I also haven't
played this game before oh snap the
Mail's here no we're getting a lot of
job
this mailbox is looking like my gmail
never inbox zero yeah inbox Sierra
doesn't exist welcome to a rescue team
okay
hold the badge up it does the rest by
advancing through your adventure sorry
all good should we train oh we got two
tickets to the dojo nice
okay the OE oh we have to read the news
we do they're right let's go beep if
it's true we have not read the news oh
wait was it right there oh this oh oh
did we reel that cool we're good
oh right well on to the next job
no I like that cinematic effect I like
what he walks like this they did that on
purpose
Underwood case try to go to tiny ones
last time it wasn't sparkly sorry we've
got a mission to do you know thank you
Sam
[Music]
I know it's full of bingo game
[Music]
money we should go to the bank after
this yeah Oh cuz if we die and we have
all this money and I didn't I think we
keep the money actually don't know but
we lose the items that we think that
right right so this is the floor that
our person is that there's a lot of
stuff over here so I'm absolutely gonna
be greedy you know get it get the money
set stones or spikes throw opening x-men
you go to your toolbox
all right so you think you know what
Charlie's just spinning no deal jet oh
oh oh oh no
double-team yeah
[Music]
we value
hello yay what do they need got it okay
yes unknown kind of said you lose money
too if you're beaten dungeon twice or in
the bank okay we got to put our money
away you were right perfect request r/a
on this point let's get it oh wait
[Music]
I could try mender is just like fast
ever yeah seriously we haven't set him
in the fall he doesn't need it he had a
big breakfast
there they are knitting yes
Thunder Wave can re yeah are you gonna
blame them tiny baby
[Music]
yeah absolutely
yeah don't worry but we got you so I
feel like this is a great game for kids
but it's also good for those who are
nostalgic for the original yeah so you
probably be into it if you play the
original when you were kid
[Music]
so fine
[Music]
strong I'm like shocked every time they
don't dive a second charlie hits them
like what he's strong boy we should give
toto an apple soon can you go on for a
little bit more
[Music]
yeah let's find out
[Music]
Billy cookie
oh he's just over here his own thing
Thanks
thanks charlie yeah Charlie's a good pal
oh and now he's dead
[Music]
like I said I like the charlie is so
strong even though he didn't eat
anything yeah hey you had a big
breakfast
[Music]
[Applause]
yes trying to save our money yeah as of
right now I can't picture dying in a
John's dungeon but you never in fact
that it's possible must mean that it
does get difficult to a point there was
one point where we have like two
pokemons and like corner us and that
might be just foreshadowing yeah so we
control the main character you can
switch between like the first one or the
second one and then the AI controls the
second one you're welcome thank you
right so we gotta go to storage pick up
the goods and then go to date some items
away to you rainbow gummy yummies
[Music]
yes
[Music]
Charlie so responsible is like it's
bedtime now we go back to town
Oh your dreams Oh Sam no it's not co-op
am i dreaming again
it's that Pokemon again
[Music]
I can't hear them clearly what are they
saying an earthquake
oh it's getting worse for a dream this
feels strangely real but the
anticipation of what's going on in this
dream I know like who is that who's
talking can't see us of course
[Laughter]
[Music]
who's done this
[Music]
abducted ruffian ruffian all right let's
get Charlie and we're out cutter
kidnapped leg drop you have to do it
yeah it's a kidnapping you have to do it
have to go Charlie better be out here
Charlie there's a kidnapped child area
good old Charlie and they're all so
angry so buddy
okay mouth full of rage bye-bye you
would have darkness yo I never it's
great so now like he just should we put
up a wall here oh that we can use nice I
was I kind of assumed we could store our
money
erase this version over there
let's get our items origin item
[Music]
Oh dreads ago right now right now I'm
trying to like okay no I just was I
guess the money doesn't go here no it
goes at the bank with the Persian
[Music]
you might want to hold on to that yeah
oh actually I should be depositing more
stuff right
[Music]
store I have a lot of see you might need
some of this yeah I'll leave it
[Music]
come on me
ooh 2277 let's go upset this is one my
favorite games I'm glad it's back yeah I
just came out on Friday
oh hold on two-twenty what do you think
of the art in this new version it will
guard it jealously woo then we got an
apple for the pub noise nice I can't my
baby back
alright now let's go see piglet yeah
must tend to this kidnapping
mount steel we must go boom he got a
great scholar this one's gonna be harder
yeah well we have a boss I think I
slowly got the jail
[Music]
9f thank you velvet farewell
[Music]
here we go
[Music]
we gotta get through nine floors gonna
be a lot
[Music]
oh there's one
yes all the way up
yeah we got one of those revive receipts
from someone write the chatter
Butterfree gave it to us I think for
saving her baby hardened offenses went
up all right so what removal I didn't
want that
[Music]
these guys are stronger all right so
thumbs neither a little tougher oh I am
it cuz I'm not actually looking at him
[Music]
[Applause]
boom yes they were much tougher yeah
[Music]
check your teammates moves remove
setting in the x-ray
[Music]
didn't even need to do it right there
charlie
planning game last seed I accidentally
the slumber trap like those yeah they're
letting us down but they are nothing
level up get it charlie
yes you want toilet
[Music]
probably Flame Burst that one's been
holding this down though but it's a
stronger version oh is it
unless you just don't want your agony
greater your level the further this
mystery okay see this umbrella so this
one shoots for titles away and this one
shoots to towels okay both of those got
it
oh you wanted to get rid of fighters
from yeah get rid of bites all right
boom now we get to long range
projectiles women
avoid avoid I love the way
[Music]
pepperi them with projectiles all the
way through
[Music]
he was chasing us
in a circulant trying to get away from
him oh I gotta see them something
of one
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
gotcha
[Music]
and there
oh that is like one of my most
frequently used words how old surely eat
if you can buy
[Laughter]
[Music]
gotta heal charlie
yes I feel great
[Music]
yes
how dare he put hands on my charlie
dislike
there's a lot of little tunnels here
[Music]
money
[Music]
y'all keep but I'm going back and forth
to get the bosses we want a 9 right yes
[Music]
where is it Derrida yeah yeah going up
[Music]
protect charlie at all caught yeah yeah
[Music]
I'm getting hungry Apple
[Music]
nice or we've got a Diglett to see if I
must save the Diglett
[Music]
no not this guy again oops wrong one
[Music]
yeah
Oh trying to range keep the stat it's a
normal mood
we're getting arranged with booths it's
so it's just a boost yeah so it's not
necessarily something so you can also
refuse it hold up some so this seating
like you want to give up I'm learning
rate then said this track is a banger
for sure yeah yeah a lot of good songs
in this game
[Music]
not that way
- featured
[Music]
oh there it is 5f alright only four more
[Music]
so far nice okay toes not the raging
type anyway exactly
[Music]
I dare you set foot out of my face okay
to comment says soundtrack reminds me of
a Mega Man X from SMEs yeah yo 30
damaged and Charlie water gun
[Music]
right
[Music]
I'm gonna lower you manacles yeah Big
Apple it really did pick the right
character constantly hungry yeah it's a
mood yeah he stares getting close seven
to Moore's thanks damn thanks for coming
by confusion confuse okay
oh nice the stairs were in a very
[Music]
one more yes this looks like a massive
[Music]
toes so close Oh
[Music]
oh boy oh boy - father course around we
got so close by death we can't go down
like this
Charlie turn around I faked out that
flame break is too good so it's
definitely Menace up the ante on that
one and my water gun is also pretty
cheap so I need to replenish them and
now we're all
[Music]
so it looks like a 3ds game yeah because
this is a remake of a 2005 game of
pokemon mystery dungeon blue and red but
this is all grouped into one game for
rescue teams and I'm trying to get in
front of it but I can't right now
let me through chop the win visit the
city what you're doing dragon rage
defense
alrighty here we go making it number
nine
Wow Aylin on a blast rap out you dig
lifts over there he's over can we jump I
don't know if we can make it lizard
browser here the surfers are here to
help you uh yeah we gotta fight Skarmory
first oh dang I should have ate some
stuff it's fine oh yeah you know hey
look how dare you it's terrified slept
in days earthquakes frighten me so
no that doesn't that doesn't excuse
kidnapping he's blaming a whole
earthquake on tickle is just not sure
well it's Jude lately but it would take
more than diglettz family random
alkalotic on CC
charlie's very logical yeah I really
appreciate that about her oh those are
fightin words
Jane callin em out okay so we have all
of our stats back
oh boy oh boy deep and boss fight I'm
trying to turn it down Toto yes I'm
trying to like get away yeah I walked it
too close to Charlie it's okay Charlie's
got this he's got the flame bursts okay
well if I'm gonna stake wait did he die
oh did we die I think Oh Charlie Opie Oh
coward well that's what you get for
kidnapping I know it's illegal
[Music]
Riley is so understanding does Charlie
evolve I don't know are there evolutions
for your partner in this game I haven't
played this game please answer in the
chat good question I know there is also
a few new features but like compared to
the original to this one they added a
few new things
[Music]
oh snap their pink unknown said you and
your partner can only evolve after
beating the main game god yeah I was
like I think I remember hearing
something similar to that being a new
thing in this version though I wasn't
100% sure that's not good pun the cache
[Laughter]
yeah did it bronze dojo ticket maybe we
should check out the dojo is this the
new game yeah this came out on Friday he
said my feet feel like they're still
walking
let's have feet what see see he has them
feet okay I'm very aware they're very
self-aware what see what did dig like
feet look like do I want to know I
imagine them just being big and floppy
like bigger than his own body been said
I love this game so much as a kid I
loved the relationship between you and
your partner yeah it's so pure I know
I'm enjoying it a lot so far he really
is the home you know
[Music]
worried Oh dig what you've been through
a lot
he's so tough oh I know we just got a
whole rescue squad going down right now
[Music]
very wholesome once again she was like
are you evolved forms or practically I'm
impressed sincerely thank you all right
see you later guys stay safe
they had a shrimp niggly you choose your
starting Pokemon a partner so you take a
personality quiz at the beginning and
that's how her Chi got paired up with
Totodile they used her answers and they
decide she was a totodile and then we
got to choose our partner but you can't
pick the same type of Pokemon as you so
we couldn't pick side up because we were
already a water-type so we went with
Charmander 800
time okay what is it
join us yes oh my gosh join us join us
one of us one of us it's okay you could
be a lizard bro even if you're a madman
we'll put a couple extra Z's for the by
lizard bros toto don't you think so it's
you yes yes the more the merrier the
world of Pokemon is the hidden pearl oh
my goodness Richie
oh no rich you had Ritchie looked up the
dig let's eat I don't want to know what
they look like some fan interpretations
are cute and some are dot that dot not I
might look that up later and I may never
look that up ever that's okay I got
stuff to do it's fine we understand we
do we need to make a village for our
team lately tough yay all right you got
it yeah we gotta get a home for our
homies ya got a star community yeah more
dreams yo what's up with this human
inside the Totodile everyday about
[Music]
my role so close to the answers that's
so far all right bits and pieces we're
getting closer though do you think if we
had a house for them
man it's ok someone else will join us
the next morning we're gonna go get him
a house and ask him and get yeah they
did say if you had a house we would have
joined unless that was just an excuse
yeah let's get a house something
actually we're really busy we did it
thanks for joining us have a good one
[Music]
tototo Charlie about the dreams
[Music]
nikasha also googled the piglet feet
sorry to send you down the spag those
dreams have some nations hide I also
appreciate how understanding Charlie is
cuz he's like you said you're a human
right
ok well yeah likely just took us at face
value is like okay so you're a human but
you look like a totodile do we want to
turn back into a human
no I haven't thought about it much it
depends on like how crappy your human
life was
hi I'm not sure yes it is a dilemma it's
true alright
sex all right anyway we're still gonna
be back for a baby remember yeah
[Music]
wigglytuff's camp corner
oh boy his next-door
no but what's happening here
okay we're looking for a Wigglytuff
please going back I was too curious
yeah there's Wigglytuff
so cute
nice men Pokemon worldís is so great I
love it
Oh a special deal thank you wow that's
way too generous
[Music]
Wow Akash my name is chastity and all
right you have a question for me would
would I rather be a human or a Pokemon
and what I turned back I would like to
turn into a Pokemon but be able to turn
back I would like to turn to a Pokemon
whenever you want just like yeah like at
this very moment and but I want to know
that I can turn back
[Music]
kidding everyone wants to get Luther
Brown we all want stretch
[Music]
congratulations go to the power plant
now nice
while Wigglytuff is so generous we got
like four camps for free
Ericsson I cannot wait to play this as
for what you can turn into so you can
become at the beginning of the game you
take a personality quiz and this is the
list you can be Bulbasaur squirtle
Charmander cyndaquil Totodile Chikorita
Treecko Torchic Mudkip Pikachu Eevee
Machop cubone sigh dog meows and skiddy
so those are the ones that you can turn
into after taking a personality quiz
[Music]
so horrible noise
yes yes
how about
oh I got the best one what is it we're
gonna know this again I finish this all
right
yes what's the happiest Megan you know
I've ever seen cute
why the magnet looks so cute you can go
to your rescue team camps by taking the
left
okay they only get two people at a time
look with your rescue work help us
tremendously do more money to put away
and stuff a commotion Oh what's
happening
he said no wow this team's greedy they
don't oh that's not nice
lead we'll do it oh yeah tell them
alphas down exactly get this week rescue
team out of here
Kurt uh-huh yeah it so we thought oh man
he was shook alakazam kind of [ __ ] got
him he was like you know I'm gonna know
what I can do oh look at the squad
look at his squad yeah yeah yeah the way
they rolled up that was definite you
don't know they're the most famous
rescue team around these parts
[Music]
takes great pride in småland body an
amazing strength yeah that's the leader
al Kazan al gazaam doesn't like the
school attacks he fights with psychic
powers he died with an amazing brain and
I could do with 5,000 apparently he's
memorized everything that's happened in
the world wow that's a lot of knowledge
[Music]
exam does all the commanding and the
teams clearly in charge
yeah exactly
nice nice oh he's a real he's a real
friend yeah he's an atta boy cold the
rain rescue team ooh I wonder what our
arranges right now oh he just knew he
was like we noticed I know everything
and you guys are not familiar what is
this what's up hello
we just started we're new nothing no he
knows 5,000 IQ knows he looked at me
once and say you're a human around he's
like that's not a Pokemon yeah they turn
around
Oh
[Music]
he's so high what Oh
Gengar excuse me sir he's up to no good
the next morning that Gengar thing are
doing well no dreams at night yep
no Gardevoir is that time
[Music]
oh let's do our best
very anime of them
[Music]
why thank you I wanted to check it
[Music]
special edition we should read that oh
nice
introducing rainbow camis wouldja granny
has yeah and now I know why I couldn't
take it out of storage came to our
gummies gamers of camps
over the world they're tasty and on top
of that the occasional that you require
a mysterious power called prayer quality
is an interesting name for a power
they're quite precious sorry let's
celebrate
Oh a giveaway three Wow
we're rolling in it we got one for each
of our members now hmm ours are the
storage good be the best rescue team all
right
yo Magnus Oh what should we go get him
first and then take him tonight
[Music]
yes
[Music]
can't get him yeah alright maybe you
have to go get Magneto first
[Music]
so we've got a few minutes left in the
stream five to be exact
thank you guys for joining us today and
if you want to play this this is pokemon
mystery dungeon rescue team DX on the
middle time to switch oh there's those
little sprites very Charlie came by oh
[Music]
this is where I can change my part oh
[Music]
okay we can eat the gummies from here
there it is okay do I want right now
should we use them chat should we use
the green book I'm use right now let us
know we'll use them and then we'll do
one one more dungeon and then we'll wrap
up
he grew explosively everyone gets a
gummy yeah Oh remembers you have on your
team more likely is the Pokemon
something something sweet alright look
at scenery I'm curious oh it lets you
see this oh yeah the background that
beautiful art in the background
beautiful 2d art
[Music]
but up
[Music]
did I pick up any I don't think I have
any quests in there
okay cool
[Music]
yeah Magneto yeah that's a really cute
name so so great all right we out
depart oddity cave here we go
alright here we go are you a bi last at
dungeon yes this our last dungeon we've
got a few minutes left in the street
I don't think I accept it in your quest
so we might just as you know on the hunt
I guess
oh are we not of us were just wondering
I don't pick one up maybe I should have
gone to pick one up real quick I don't
know if we would just randomly run into
them if we didn't know their quest right
like something that's going on in this
cave already behind you guys are just
taking him out oh how dare you Tara
while he's strong okay it was a strong
yato
where you going go that way
get that Apple
let me stay in let me leave
ow
that actually really hurt oh no no my
god she just got
Wow one hit me Wow Wow we're gonna try
to get this guy and then we are not only
are we in here without a quest what it's
getting bleak
no it's hit around oh don't kill toto
yeah this is disrespect
[Music]
oh wait no that was for under it oh yeah
I know one day other berry yeah okay
we need to vacate the premises oh of
course I stepped on a trap
hurry this is no joke remember earlier
when I got a heel among use the RM berry
Oh
[Music]
there you go wake up better yeah
leave my friends alone okay that
Caterpie should not be this get out some
good questions
[Music]
there was really strong in here I know I
said in this case you can use an escape
orb to leave a dungeon without losing
anything thank do you have an item I
think we had one of those
that's a helper orb is that it no
[Music]
another Russ team will come and help you
we don't have an escape ward okay so now
you don't use that yet yeah yeah cuz I
kind of ran in here and was like we was
charged and ready for adventure
I just wanted to use Magneto
[Music]
turning voice no Charlie's Charlie come
back hey don't be making fun people done
own a switch 20 20
I don't own a switch in 20 you're
getting on though my order got canceled
yes it was a part of like I guess they
sold to Vinny and I got my email and
they were like sorry that's really
disappointing I never gonna get that
super cute animal process really sorry
alright so since we don't have an escape
or it and I also did not get a quest
we're gonna go ahead and in the gameplay
after we defeat this Caterpie alright
done but yeah if you guys want to play
this game it's pokemon mystery dungeon
rescue team DX it's on the Nintendo
switch it just came out on Friday so you
can check that out if you're in a static
for the old game it's a remake of the
old one from 2005 put them both red and
blue into one game so you get all the
Pokemon from both of them in one yeah
it's pretty nice yeah and it's got
really cute art on it and great music I
really really liked it it's definitely
getting more difficult so now I'm more
inclined to like continue this for the
challenge
yeah that's like my wonder is you know
it's gonna be this easy all the way
around but no it's definitely leveling
up it's getting harder I like it I'm
gonna check it out some more and I'm
gonna keep on making these awesome
nicknames for all of my they're very
tears lizard Bros is just growing we're
expanding yes so thank you guys so much
for tuning in don't forget you can catch
us here every single weekday at 2 p.m.
Pacific time and tomorrow we're gonna be
playing the Call of Duty war zone that's
supposed to be coming out I'm really
really excited for that super interested
since my personal interest in VR has
grown recently but we'll see be sure to
tune in for that yeah until tomorrow see
you later
have a good one happy Monday